when you stop asking permission and
start just taking Destiny in your own
hands things kind of fall into place
like that I think it was just I had the
bravado that I could make this movie
anyway I had bravado when I walked into
people's office when they look at the
script well you know we don't like this
and can you change the third act and can
you put it in a lady in it well you know
all that stuff I was like well you know
I can't you know this is the movie I
want to make and I can make it over here
this way so thank you very much but no
thank you that kind of thought process
that kind of bravado actually helped the
movie get made you wrote the the script
and then did you just present it that
way you didn't make any alterations or
anything we never even had a script
meeting they liked the script they dug
it they that's what they wanted to do
you know and this is the way I want to
work it's like you know I write the
script that it's not like you know well
you know it's about a read right away or
two rewrites away or it's like I like
this but then the third Act is still
kind of shaky no no it's like when I
write something it's like boom this is
it if you want to make this this is it
there'll be no changes this is the movie
I'm gonna make if you like this and we
should make it if you don't like this
and I'll go with somebody else who does